KRISTAN: Hey, Matt made
it just in time.
And today is 12/12/12, the last
time, I believe, any of
us on this planet currently will
experience such a date.
LES: Speak for yourself.
KRISTAN: You know, what's
a millennia
between friends, right?
So this is the last Google
TV developers
Hangout for this year.
That's why I've gathered all of
us together just to sort of
talk a little bit about what's
happened in the last little
while, what's happened
over the last year--
believe it or not, quite
a few things--
and I guess to wrap it up
with a little bit of
Q&A from the community.
I know we have some questions
that we'll get to.
And it looks like Matt's
dropped off.
Maybe he'll reconnect.
Christian and I were at
AnDevCon last week.
And what were your
impressions?
CHRISTIAN: I think
it was good.
We talked about Google TV.
We gave an overview
of developing for
television in general.
And I think a lot of the Android
developers, they're
already familiar with
phones and tablets.
And now they're just adding
another big screen to their
target audience.
KRISTAN: Everybody wants
the big screen.
CHRISTIAN: The bigger
the better.
KRISTAN: I'm actually surprised
you didn't mention
the thing that we cooked up.
CHRISTIAN: Well, yeah.
There's some reports on the
internet that we did a little
bit of a hardware teardown.
KRISTAN: We did.
That was actually quite a bit of
fun, especially donning all
the equipment and
the test thing.
So for those of you who were not
at AnDevCon and would like
to be in on this little thing
we're talking about, Christian
and I did a teardown of
Google TV hardware.
We covered pretty much
everything that developers
would care about-- the
CPU, the RAM, the--
CHRISTIAN: GPU.
KRISTAN: --GPU, the NAND
memory a little bit.
And then what we did was we put
all those parts from that
teardown into a Blendtec blender
and kind of hit grind.
CHRISTIAN: Supersonic blades.
KRISTAN: That blender
was amazing.
So the guys at Blendtec
were great.
And they sent us three
of these blenders.
I think we only destroyed
1 and 1/2
of them in our testing.
But it was pretty good.
All right, so the buildup
was this.
We've got all these people
in this room.
And we're talking about this
hardware teardown.
And we finish with the
description in the slides.
And then I'm like, all right,
I got three Google TVs.
We've got a room of
maybe 160 people.
Got to figure out how to
fairly distribute them.
So it's Let's Make
A Deal time.
And it was who had the biggest
hard drive, who had lint in
their pocket, that
sort of thing.
We give away three Google TVs.
And at this point, everyone's
like, yay, Google TV.
And then the second
question came.
And the second question was,
all right, those of you who
received Google TVs, who
wants to give it up?
CHRISTIAN: Well, we put all
the nice little hardware
things in a little Christmas
box, and then we added jelly
beans to it and all kinds
of other stuff.
KRISTAN: All the things people
were asking for, you know.
And one person took the bait.
So yeah, they kind of ended up
on stage with us, wearing some
protective gear, as I took their
Google TV away and we
proceeded to grind up the
portions of the Google TV we
had dissected earlier.
And yeah, the crowd kind
of got into that.
That was pretty good.
CHRISTIAN: We blended up all the
requirements that we hear
about from people.
KRISTAN: Yeah, we just gave
the community what it was
asking for.
As we will continue to do in
the new year, et cetera.
I had a lot of fun doing it.
LES: Which Google TV did you--
was it any particular vendor
you'd like to mention?
Or not.
KRISTAN: Nothing to announce
at this time.
They're all good.
They all fit into a
specific spectrum.
We were talking about Google
TV sort of in the general
sense, so the hardware we
covered was specific to Visio.
But what we ended up grinding
up was kind of a mixture of
various electronic components
from various
models of Google TVs.
You know, we had to
be fair, right?
I think the conclusion we
reached was it does not blend.
CHRISTIAN: Well, we probably
didn't blend it long enough.
KRISTAN: We need more
practice at this.
I think we'll be doing something
like this again in
the future.
LES: Maybe at I/O.
KRISTAN: Yeah, well, at
I/O, we got to have
the industrial grinder.
And we got to put a whole LG
TV in there or something.
I don't know.
Maybe we'll just say,
bring your hardware
and we'll grind it.
LES: But OK, yeah.
KRISTAN: So AnDevCon
was pretty good.
Met a lot of speakers who I
hadn't met before, because I
guess I'm kind of new
to the circuit.
And I had a lot of fun.
CHRISTIAN: Yeah.
I mean, it was really
a lot of--
I want to say quality
Android developers.
It was a lot of people who have
written apps, who have
published apps.
It's a fun, fun crowd.
KRISTAN: So if you weren't
there this year, there's
another one, I believe,
in the spring.
Well, there's one in Boston,
isn't there?
CHRISTIAN: Yeah,
Boston spring.
But also the slides
are available.
So people can just go to the
website and check it out.
KRISTAN: Some of them may not
make sense without us
speaking, though.
Eh.
Come to one of our other
presentations.
Matt, since I have you on the
line, maybe you can talk a
little bit about the exclusive
European programming that was
announced recently.
He's blinking.
He's on the spot.
He doesn't know what to say.
Or he's muted.
LES: He's trying to
find his notes.
KRISTAN: I can't
hear you, Matt.
I think you might be muted.
Les, can you hear him?
LES: I do not hear him.
He's going to controller, so
he's in a studio somewhere.
KRISTAN: Yes.
MATT: How about now?
KRISTAN: Now we can hear you.
LES: Oh, that's right.
Are you guys in the studio,
or are you in 1808?
MATT: I'm in a ad hoc little
space at the moment.
We're getting a studio built
in this building, but
it's not there yet.
KRISTAN: So to answer Les's
question, we're in 1808.
I cleaned up the room
a little bit today.
I put a nice tablecloth down.
Felt we should be more
professional in our
presentation.
CHRISTIAN: All right.
And next week, we iron
the tablecloth.
LES: Excellent.
So what happened this year?
KRISTAN: Well, actually, before
we get to what happened
this year--
LES: Oh, right.
Matt was going to talk.
KRISTAN: Yeah, Matt was going
to talk about the European
programming.
And I'm going to mute Stoyan.
MATT: So what do you want to
know about the European
programming?
KRISTAN: Well, for those of us
who are not in Europe, perhaps
you could fill us in.
MATT: So I've been running
around for the past six months
since I've joined kind of
prepping all of the developer
community for the Google TV
launches in UK, France,
Germany, and Netherlands, and
just kind of making them aware
of the platforms and some of the
dos and don'ts, and what
they can and can't do
with Google TV.
So yeah, it's been exciting
times over here.
So I'm just getting all the
developers interested and
hyped up, and starting to see
some of the great things that
they've been producing.
KRISTAN: Cool.
That's it?
Nothing else to add?
No.
LES: Would you like to talk
about any launched apps or
launched new content.
MATT: Well, at the moment, I'm
still working with a load of
partners and a load of
developers that have started
sending through loads and loads
of really cool things.
But a lot of them are still
trying to do it in a much
larger picture, so they're
trying to do it with a whole
suite of Android applications
as well as Google TV.
And obviously, with all the
Nexus 7 and 10, et cetera, I
think they want to do
that big launch.
They want to be able to hit
all of these devices.
So I'm seeing a lot of stuff
come through and a lot of
interconnected stuff.
But none of them are launched
yet, so still waiting for it.
But it's going to happen.
It's going to be great.
But yeah, I've been going to
all the Droidcon events, as
well as a load of Android
user group events.
The communities are
just incredible.
They're so welcoming and there's
just so much kind of
enthusiasm for all of the
Android platform.
So yeah, Google TV, they're just
as absolutely loving the
fact they've got another form
factor, another way of
reaching their audience, and
an entirely new audience.
So yeah, it's been awesome.
KRISTAN: Cool.
Les, do you want to talk
about the V3 roll-out?
LES: Sure.
But first I'm going to
talk about today's
event, give a plug for--
on 12/12/12, Google, for the
12th year running, has
announced Google Zeitgeist.
And for the first time, the
Google Zeitgeist Android
application launched today.
And that's what I and another
Googler have been working on
all weekend, was getting
that launched.
And so I am plugging it.
So get your Google Zeitgeist
2012 Android application fresh
from market for your phone.
KRISTAN: Cool, congratulations.
I remember--
so I received an email from
Les over the weekend, can
people help test this,
and pulled it up on
all my Android devices.
And it was really stable,
actually.
LES: It was amazing.
Yeah, I didn't write
it, but I put it
through all our process.
And we had to put
it into-- yeah.
Our process is insane.
I'm told we were the fastest
getting through the process
that the Android
team has seen.
So.
I
KRISTAN: Nice.
LES: I got recruited
Friday night.
KRISTAN: Oh, wow.
That explains the email
Saturday morning.
LES: Yes.
So V3 has launched
on the LGTV.
It is giving advanced
media VPIs--
quality of service,
the DASH codec,
really good audio codecs.
And you have the ability in Java
to add your own codecs.
So that if you've got a
proprietary video or audio
format, you can basically
decode that on a
Google TV now from Java.
CHRISTIAN: And you don't need
native code for that.
LES: No, you don't.
CHRISTIAN: No NDK required.
LES: [INAUDIBLE]
code at all.
KRISTAN: Actually, it's funny.
I remember in university--
let me just click on us
so we're focused--
I remember university, I took
this Fundamentals of
Multimedia Programming.
And this was back a little
while ago, shall we say.
And we had to write JPEG
and MPEG encoders
and decoders in Java.
And I was shocked at how
performant they were, even in
comparison to the C code that we
had been writing in one of
the other courses.
So you know.
That was on hardware that's
much older and much slower
than the Google TV.
So I expect everybody who's ever
had an issue with a codec
not being supported for their
particular application, now
you can go up there
and write them.
CHRISTIAN: Actually, one plug.
So as preparation for AnDevCon,
when we were talking
about all that hardware, I
wanted to see what that
hardware really can do.
And I dug into Renderscript
and took a bunch of the
samples, modified them,
and ran them.
And I was really impressed.
I was doing some video effects
and I was doing some--
basically, I think I had 2,000
sprites on the screen moving
around and didn't
drop a frame.
So pretty cool.
KRISTAN: There's a lot of power
behind that hardware.
Right.
So there is nothing else that
I have on the immediate use
that we can talk about.
So instead, let's jump into
a sort of year in review.
And those of you on the team,
remember the email I sent out
this morning.
Somebody needs to mute.
And it's Matt.
There we go.
LES: It's actually--
Stoyan's mic keeps coming on.
And so if he'd stay mute
until he asks a
question, that'd be good.
KRISTAN: So I haven't been on
the team very long, maybe--
I guess I'm getting close
to six months now.
Wow, six months.
LES: Actually, it would be close
to six months, because
you kind of started a
couple weeks before
the end of the quarter.
So it's actually is important.
KRISTAN: Sneaks up on you.
I still feel like the new guy.
I still act like the new guy.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
KRISTAN: So when I was trying
to figure out what we would
cover in this last Hangout for
the year, I thought it would
be really good to just cover
sort of a year in review,
where we were this time last
year, and where we are now and
the evolution.
Because I think a lot of the
times, we're so focused on the
stuff that we're doing or a
particular application that
you lose the context of how much
is actually going on, and
how much movement there is.
So I know I solicited all of
you for different things.
Maybe we can just
start off with--
you mentioned Android Market
in your response, so.
CHRISTIAN: Yeah.
I mean, it's pretty amazing to
think that only a year ago,
we've actually launched the
ability for third party
developers to distribute
applications to Google TV.
So at the time it was
Android market.
Now it's Google Play Store.
But that's only a year ago.
So for all the developers out
there, it has been a really
busy year developing apps for
Google TV for the first time,
getting their feet wet.
I think we've made a
lot of progress.
When I look in market now,
there's a lot of really cool
apps that have shown up over
the last 12 months.
KRISTAN: People are starting
to figure it out.
LES: We released V2.
Then we released 2.1, 2.2--
or excuse me, 1, [? 2.1.2. ?]
And we also released--
KRISTAN: Well, there's a
Honeycomb update in there as
well, right?
CHRISTIAN: Yeah, the Honeycomb
update brought in market,
effectively.
And yeah, we did a couple
updates over the year to--
especially the old hardware.
So the Intel-based Sony Blu-ray
players, the K device
is still getting updates.
And so we added market.
Initially, we had a Google TV
specific market client.
And now with the Google Play
update, we have the official--
just the same binary that's
on all the other devices.
It is the Google Play
Android store.
KRISTAN: The full experience.
CHRISTIAN: The full
experience.
Same as on the tablet.
It's actually a tablet UI.
KRISTAN: Yes.
Unless you haven't done
the overscan.
CHRISTIAN: Yeah, there is a
bug or two in there still.
KRISTAN: There's always bugs,
but we're working on it.
It's always this constant
driving to fix the problems
that we create and--
LES: I'm not sure that's
the direction
you want to be headed.
But it looks like Krispy's
disappeared.
MATT: Oh.
We occasionally get this
over the pond.
They'll come back
in in a second.
It'll be fine.
LES: Yeah, or something
changed.
It says we're still on air,
but usually, when the
moderator disappears,
we go off.
But hopefully somebody will ping
us with some information.
MATT: So Les, what was your main
thing for google TV over
the past year?
KRISTAN: We're still here.
MATT: Oh, there we go.
KRISTAN: I don't know
what happened.
Somebody pulled something
out of something.
LES: Well, it still has you
connected and a good still
shot down at the bottom.
KRISTAN: OK.
Well, we're back now--
--but I guess we launched
some arm hardware
this year as well.
And some new devices.
LES: Yeah.
Do we know we're still being
recorded is the question.
KRISTAN: It says at the top of
mine that the broadcast is
still going and that we have
a bunch of viewers.
Quite a few viewers.
LES: OK, so you're seeing
moderator information.
That's what I asked.
OK, cool.
KRISTAN: Yes.
LES: OK.
So we're still going, then.
KRISTAN: We're still going.
Sorry about that blip, people.
So yes.
New hardware.
This was kind of the big,
exciting thing, because--
CHRISTIAN: Yeah.
And we talked about it almost a
year ago at CS in Las Vegas.
We, for the first time, talked
about new devices with Marvell
chip set, going to an arm CPU.
And at the time, we talked
about LG and--
I don't know who else
we announced.
But throughout the year, we
basically rolled out the LGTV
with the Google TV built in,
which I think is a really
great experience.
There's no extra set-top
box needed.
It's right on the TV.
And then we have, of course,
the Sony device.
They did a refresh with an
army base with Marvell.
We have the Visio devices
and we're still going.
We were adding hardware
to the mix.
KRISTAN: And according to
ifixit.com, the Visio device
is very fixable.
CHRISTIAN: Doesn't really
blend, though.
KRISTAN: Does not
blend at all.
CHRISTIAN: The heat sink
is quite massive.
KRISTAN: Well, we didn't
even try--
just as a little side note here,
we didn't even try to
blend the heat sink
on the Visio.
But the screws and the bolts on
the motherboard, once they
get bouncing around at something
like 1700 RPM or
something like that, those
blades were really going fast.
It was the hum.
They were dinging around
inside of this blending
container and sparking.
And I think-- oh.
CHRISTIAN: Should have
made a video of our--
PAUL: So you made soup, then.
It warmed itself up.
KRISTAN: Yeah, we
made metal soup.
But even the circuit boards
were just like-- they were
chewing, but they
went in square.
They came out kind
of cookie shaped.
Because they were just bouncing
around and rotating.
Anyway.
Sorry, I didn't mean to
digress that much.
But yeah, the Visios are
fun to take apart.
Shawn, you had put a bunch of
stuff on the historical list.
You're like the custodian
of our history and--
SHAWN: Well, I looked through
our Google TV blog posts.
KRISTAN: So I don't know.
To talk to some of the points
that you had on there.
SHAWN: Well, like you sort of
add it to your questions
pointed out, it's the
year where we had a
lot of Android apps.
Before, going into that, we had
the Google TV spotlight,
where we had about
60, 70, 80 apps.
And then throughout the year,
a lot of the developers
actually converted some of the
web apps into Android apps.
So thank you very much
for that effort.
And now, I think, more than half
of the older the web apps
have already been converted into
Android apps, so that's a
great accomplishment
for the year.
So thanks a lot for
the great work.
We also launched Google TV--
on Google+, we launched a Google
TV page and also Google
TV developers page.
And on the Google TV
page, we've got
like 350,000 followers.
And the Google TV developer
page, we've got
almost 12,000 followers.
So thanks a lot for
participating in the community.
A lot of the things, I think
you guys already mentioned.
I think there is also the
"Gangnam Style" [INAUDIBLE]
Google+ launch in Korea.
KRISTAN: Yes.
SHAWN: That was a lot of fun.
LES: Oh, and that's just
going amazing.
KRISTAN: Well, it's a
full IP TV, right?
LES: Yeah, and it's U+ is the
cable company, and they're
just installing it everywhere.
MATT: And people have got the
option to upgrade for a small
fee, but it sounds like everyone
who's on that surface
is jumping over the chance of
getting this Google TV box.
It's fantastic, isn't it?
LES: Yeah.
It's pretty amazing.
KRISTAN: Makes me really wish
we had fiber in California.
CHRISTIAN: Yeah, no kidding.
KRISTAN: As I'm sure many of you
who are watching this now
will agree.
LES: Great if we could
find a company that
would provide fiber.
KRISTAN: Maybe we should do a
road trip to Kansas next year
and we should film it.
LES: Actually, what we should
do is we should
go do a code lab.
We should find out if
Kansas City has a
Android developers group.
KRISTAN: Awesome.
CHRISTIAN: Actually, if there's
any Android developers
listening here--
KRISTAN: In Kansas City.
CHRISTIAN: --in Kansas City.
KRISTAN: You should
be joining us.
PAUL: So that can bring up what
I've spent a lot of my
time on this last year.
We started out doing
some code labs.
Realized it could be quite a
challenge to set up a ton of
monitors in a room to allow
people to actually do an
interactive code lab.
And especially as we sort of
see, I think, more interest
over the year.
More people wanted to show
up to our events.
So we transitioned to what we
call the Google TV Test Lab
and have gotten some pretty
good response.
We've done it in Washington, DC,
we did one in Boulder, and
we're planning out what we're
going to do for next year.
So if the developers out there
want us to come to them, the
way that these work really
well is we get your help.
You help us set them up with
meet-ups and Google Developer
groups, Android developer
groups, whomever.
But it's been really good,
because these test labs, we
bring TVs in and we side load
your apps on there.
We try them out.
And you get to see how they
can perform on all the
different devices.
We have a Sony, the LG, and the
Visio devices all there
lined up ready to go
and try them out.
KRISTAN: And pretty soon,
we'll have the
High Sense and the--
PAUL: High Sense is coming.
KRISTAN: And the--
LES: The others are-- haven't
announced yet.
KRISTAN: Right.
CHRISTIAN: Nothing to announce
at this time.
LES: Go use your favorite
search engine.
I think something's out there.
I'm not saying anything.
I just wanted to make sure.
KRISTAN: There was something
else-- oh yeah, you were
mentioning.
So I think you did the smart
thing, because Shawn and I
went to Seattle this year and
I organized 30 monitors and
Google TVs.
And there was a lot of shipping
of stuff going on.
And it was a lot of work, so.
PAUL: But there are times when
you still need them.
And we are doing hackathons,
so--
KRISTAN: There's one coming
up, actually.
PAUL: Well, we've done three.
Well, let's see.
We've done two this year
and we're getting
ready to our third.
The first one, we
did in April.
We had 200 developers here in
[INAUDIBLE], which was great.
We did the London hackathon
in July.
We had about 50 to 60 developer
show up for that one.
And we're doing a hackathon in
LA on January 26 and 27.
And if you are interested
in going to that--
boy, I don't remember.
I think it's YouTube hack LA
or something like that,
ythackla.com.
Something like that.
KRISTAN: If you can't find it
and you're interested in
going, send me an email.
PAUL: Yep, look it up.
We're looking for developers
to show up there and it's a
hackathon for the weekend.
We're really excited about that
one because it's in LA.
You've got content people there,
people who have things
that they want to get
distributed to people.
It's an opportunity for you to
build an app to get their
stuff out there.
KRISTAN: It's already pretty
full, isn't it?
PAUL: Yeah, we're doing
pretty well.
We're probably 70%
full right now.
KRISTAN: OK, so--
CHRISTIAN: If we only had
a way to show YouTube
content on Google TV.
If only.
Huh.
It's funny you should
mention that.
LES: Wait till--
KRISTAN: Yeah.
LES: Yeah.
Unfortunately, not yet.
KRISTAN: We were already talking
about this a little
bit at AnDevCon.
So it's kind of already
out there.
It's coming.
LES: Well, I've talked about
it on these things too.
I was just going to wait
because the official
announcement might happen
real shortly.
KRISTAN: That's true.
So read between the lines.
LES: Well.
That said, as long as we're
going to plug events, Jarek
from the YouTube team and I
are doing an eight-hour
workshop at South by Southwest
called "Saving the Couch
Potatoes: the Cloudy Future
of Television."
KRISTAN: So that should
be pretty exciting.
LES: And we're going to take
you through the process of
filming content, creating a
content delivery network, and
creating apps to highlight that
content and display it
and monetize N analytics.
So that should be
a great event.
And it's at South by Southwest
Interactive.
KRISTAN: Cool.
I wish I could announce
something, but there's nothing
to announce.
CHRISTIAN: At this time.
KRISTAN: At this time, yeah.
Anyway, that's pretty exciting,
actually, about
South by Southwest.
Hopefully some of you have the
chance to go to that, because
I think that is one of the most
requested things with, at
least, Google TV.
I want more control over video
and getting it out there.
What else do we want
to talk about?
We talked about Korea.
We've talked about kind of V3
and the voice search and
functionality that goes along
with that, our re-brand of TV
and movies to PrimeTime.
So if you hear PrimeTime as a
developer, we're referring to
what was TV and movies.
Apps on Google Play, we've
talked about, Pandora--
oh, actually.
Maybe you want to talk about
just who's launched this year.
CHRISTIAN: That's what--
it was a busy year.
So all the usual suspects
that were preloaded
originally are in market.
So Pandora.
They are always a very
popular application.
People love listening to
music and watching TV
on their TV, naturally.
Some of the other apps that in
that area is aVia Media Player
and then Plex Media Player.
Also, GTV box.
So those are all apps that allow
you to control media
servers in your home.
You can stream videos from your
media server to your TV.
And then, of course, there is a
lot of media games or media
applications, like Redux,
DramaFever,
SnagFilms, Viki, Post TV.
So what we see is most of the
really interesting and
successful applications revolve
around bringing some
sort or another of video or
media to the television.
So a lot of people who already
have video on demand services
have created Google TV apps.
And then we have games.
So Greed Spiders is one that
we featured recently.
We're always reviewing
for our staff picks.
And there's a few more
games that we have.
Canabalt was another nice one.
Very easy to use on
a remote control.
All you need is left,
right, up, down.
The biggest problem with games,
other than the NDK one,
is usually the input device.
So the question is how do you
effectively control the game
without a touchpad or without
a touchscreen.
KRISTAN: Well, I remember days
of video games when you had a
controller with a wire connected
to your console.
You can use USB host
mode and build to--
LES: Well, the OnLive folks
created their own controller.
KRISTAN: That's right.
LES: And they've got quite
an amazing set
of Google TV devices.
CHRISTIAN: Yeah, I think the
launch of OnLive was really
kind of interesting.
It brought, suddenly, a lot of
console titles and good games.
KRISTAN: Well, you have access
to a great library
set that they have.
But I want to see more,
quote unquote--
I don't want to use the
word "native," but I'm
kind of forced to.
I want to see more Android
applications that are
game-specific, Google
TV-specific, and use maybe a
secondary input device.
I think that would
go a long way.
And I see Jason has joined
the Hangout.
And Jason, do you want to give
us an update on your game or
is it too premature for that?
I can't hear him if
he's talking.
LES: I muted him--
KRISTAN: Yeah, now we can.
MATT: There we go.
JASON: All right, there's a lot
of background noise here
because everybody's on
lunch right now.
But yeah, my game is still
kind of premature.
But I've been testing--
I'm trying to do a top-down
vertical shooter that's
optimized for Google TV.
Hope--
somebody's knocking
on the door--
hopefully I can get some preview
screens out and maybe
a stage, kind of a demo within
the next couple of weeks,
because I'm not that far
off from actually
having a soft demo.
But I'm trying to make it
as polished as possible.
KRISTAN: What are you using
for your input device?
JASON: Input right now is
configured for remotes, so I
have the original Blu-ray Google
TV remote and the new
black Sony Google TV box.
And I've been wanting to
work with [? Animo ?]
as a joystick control.
So I've been trying to work with
that a little bit more in
depth when I get a little
bit more time.
Definitely, OpenGL ES 2.0
is the way to go.
I've actually ran a couple
samples with Canvas, which is
just kind of just a blueprint of
how the game mechanics are
going to work.
And then I can [INAUDIBLE]
ship that over to more
production for OpenGL ES.
KRISTAN: Christian was talking
about Canvas in one of our
talks, weren't you?
About OpenGL and the
performance.
CHRISTIAN: So you can go all the
way down to the nuts and
bolts of just OpenGL and using
the OpenGL ES 2.0 APIs.
Or you can just use the
Android Canvas Draw.
And there's a bunch of vertex
draw operations that work
relatively well.
But that's more for 2D
kind of scenarios.
And when you do that, make sure
you turn on the hardware
acceleration in the manifest
or purview or whatever.
Cool.
MATT: So Krispy, this might
interest you, because I know
you're really hardcore
into your games.
Have you seen Arduino
have released a game
controller PCB board?
KRISTAN: Oh, oh,
oh, hells yes.
MATT: I thought you would.
KRISTAN: Addafruit, which
is a hardware site
online that I just--
I love the stuff they
do with Hangouts.
Yeah, I saw that board and I've
actually ordered three.
MATT: [INAUDIBLE].
KRISTAN: I only have two hands,
so I don't know what
I'm going to do with
a third one.
But I've got some
plans for it.
I mean, it's got a
microphone on it.
It's got accelerometer.
It's got a potentiometer
slider at the bottom.
Yeah, it's got the analog on one
side and you've got like
four buttons on the other.
It's great.
It's just I'm going to have to
build a case for it first.
So 3D printer, here I come.
CHRISTIAN: You know, just
because we got a storage room
doesn't mean [INAUDIBLE]
hardware.
KRISTAN: Yeah, well.
I think there's actually a lot
of hardware that I've ordered
that's starting to arrive
now as we play with.
But I love--
I mean, you're into
this too Paul.
It's like finding ways to
interface with hardware and do
cool things with Android and
controlling other things.
PAUL: Make it pour beer.
KRISTAN: That's right,
kegdroid.
Which I want keg coffee
at my desk.
PAUL: Well, we have our
second kegdroid
is online this evening.
3 o'clock, we're going
to start drinking
off of it here, so.
KRISTAN: Mm.
PAUL: Two of them are
up and running.
KRISTAN: Robotic beer.
LES: You know, with enough
coffee, you could probably
melt one of those.
KRISTAN: Does it blend?
Actually, that would
be awesome.
PAUL: There are days I would
love to see it blend, yes.
CHRISTIAN: We have some
[INAUDIBLE] to work.
KRISTAN: Actually, that would
be the margarita droid.
That's next, yes.
LES: Actually, that'd be cool.
KRISTAN: Maybe that's what you
want to do with the Google TV,
is recipes and controlling
the Blendtec blender.
Because it's got firmware.
I don't know.
LES: We have a whole bunch
of folks here.
Maybe we ought to take
some questions.
KRISTAN: Yes, I was actually
just trying to transition us
over there, but we got wrapped
up in hardware and beer and
all that stuff we
all care about.
So yeah, I'm going to
just pull up the
DORY here and ask--
or talk to the questions
that we have.
LES: Also, if you've got a live
question, you're welcome
to type it into the chat window,
for anybody who's a
member of the group.
And I will take a peek at the
various things going on.
MATT: Stoyan is straight
in there.
KRISTAN: All right.
So let me just scroll
down to the DORY.
All right.
So Shawn, you can answer
this one live.
The question is, we have
submitted a website that is a
Google TV optimized site
and it's been approved.
It's visible on the website
gallery, but it's not visible
on Spotlight.
So they wanted to know when
they'd be visible on Spotlight
Yes, we answered it here.
But for the benefit of our
viewers, why don't you--
SHAWN: Let me--
[INAUDIBLE].
There are two things.
One is called a Google TV
gallery and there's another
thing called the Google
TV Spotlight.
I Gallery is for developers to
submit your applications
online, where we do
a quick review.
And if it's good enough, we can
approve it and then you're
right there, live on
Google TV Gallery.
But that doesn't guarantee that
it's going to be in the
Google TV Spotlight.
For Spotlight our apps,
we have a little bit
more process involved.
So you have to implement a
[INAUDIBLE] navigation.
You have to get the
UIs correctly.
And then we do a team review.
At that point, we kind of work
with you guys one on one and
get everything, like your
assets, ready, and then
publish it.
MALE SPEAKER: OK, I asked this
question that Shawn answered.
SHAWN: Yes.
MALE SPEAKER: I wrote you today
because you answered me
yesterday with an email that
you want to do some things
that we should get more
categories for the homepage
and to re-shoot, polish
our design and the
part should be working.
And today me and my team
here does some work.
And we sent you an email and it
didn't get in the gallery.
So what should we do next to
be visible on Spotlight?
SHAWN: Yes.
I saw your email.
I had a look at your app.
It looks pretty good.
So I'll get back to
you in email.
MALE SPEAKER: So
it's good, OK?
And our team should wait
for you or something?
SHAWN: Yes.
MALE SPEAKER: Yes.
And we should be approved
for the Spotlight.
SHAWN: Yes, I'll get back to
your email and ask you for
more info and get assets, things
like that, in place.
And also, you guys need to
sign some documents.
MALE SPEAKER: OK.
No problem.
One more question.
Is there any restriction
for adult content?
SHAWN: Yes.
We don't allow that.
Not adult contents.
KRISTAN: Well, that's a--
we don't allow that to
show up on Play.
And there's rules around
Spotlight too.
So nothing--
yeah.
LES: That said, there are at
least two companies that have
Google TV optimized
adult content.
One an Android app.
And I'm just-- yeah.
One an Android app and
one a website that's
optimized for Google TV.
So don't let that we won't
promote it stop you if you
have other ways to promote it.
KRISTAN: Yeah.
Very delicate way
of putting it.
All right.
So I'm going to jump to the
next DORY question.
And hopefully someone can
fill me in on this.
I know very little about
selling in market.
But for try-and-buy, this person
was not-- this is Tom
in Orange County--
not exactly clear what content
I need to have in my app for
the subscription.
Could you explain this?
I'd asked for some clarification
and Matt had
added a bit of info in here.
So maybe we could just take
a second and talk about
try-and-buy.
Maybe Matt, if you want
to pipe in here.
MATT: So my interpretation of
this question is, with the
subscription side of stuff, you
can essentially say, I'm
going to give you a period where
you don't have to pay me
anything and you can have the
app and the content for x
amount of time, after which you
agree that you'll either
cancel the subscription or then
actually start paying me
the regular fee.
So that was kind of my
understanding of it.
The way the question is kind
of phrased is to say, if I
want to partake in this idea of
having a free period, what
content do I need to have?
It seems like they're kind of
looking at it the wrong way.
The way it's designed is if you
have regular content that
you think people will buy for a
subscription rate, then the
free period, the purpose of
that is to just give them
early access to that, so they
can see what they're going to
buy before they actually
buy it, essentially.
So realistically, if you're
looking at a subscription
model, then you should already
have some regular content or
some content they're going
to want access to.
And then, all you're doing
with the try-and-buy is
literally just a set period of
time where the Play still
won't charge them and you can
give them early access.
KRISTAN: So I'm a magazine
company and I've got, say,
magazines or I've got videos
or something that you would
normally pay a monthly
fee for.
I'm like, you know what, anybody
who downloads or
installs my app, they can have
30 days free access and then
I'll start billing them.
MATT: Exactly right.
CHRISTIAN: So Matt, is
there actually ways--
I know, for example, we have
support for things like in app
billing and for things like
subscriptions in the Play Store.
So if I want to implement
something like a try-and-buy,
is there actually easy
ways to do that with
our Play Store APIs?
Or do you need to add the trial
period yourself and then
manage the payments.
MATT: So there's another
question in the DORY that's
pretty much exactly this, which
is kind of saying, if I
want to give people access for
a set amount of time, then
they buy it for a
one-time fee.
There's nothing in the Play
Store that I'm aware of that
allows you to manage
everything.
Essentially, I think the way
you'd do it is it would be a
free app that they download.
And the way I recommended it
is you essentially sign up
with some form of
account details.
And then that way, your back
end server can say, right,
this is the person who's
using the app.
This is the start period.
Track them for that period of
time and then do an in app
purchase at that point.
And then from that point, you
can basically say, OK, cool.
I know what account you are.
You've paid for the app.
Here you go.
Have access.
LES: Actually, I have an idea.
Can't you have a zero
cost item in play--
that you've sort of forced them
to buy a zero cost item
that gives them their
first 30 days.
And then they need to
renew for cost.
That way, everything is stored
in play and they're not
sharing their credentials
with you.
MATT: So there's two
ways of doing it.
That would be a really
nice way of doing it.
The only question I'd have is
whether you could find out
when they purchased the first
item, to then validate how
long they've had it for.
LES: Yeah, you can.
MATT: OK, cool.
LES: The new Play Store APIs
for V3, I think, would be
where you'd want to
look for all this.
MATT: Yeah, because I know
that you can see what
purchases they've made.
It's just whether you get
information like the actual
date and time they
purchased it.
But yeah, if you can do that,
then that would be a really
nice way of doing it, because
then obviously you don't have
to maintain your back
end server.
So yeah, that would be
another alternative.
So yeah, one way or another,
you'd have to implement the
payment-free period and then
in-app purchase after that.
And we were kind of having a
discussion that a lot of users
normally prefer taking that
approach than just buying an
app up front.
It's got a much higher
conversion rate.
So yeah, it's not just handed
to you on a plate, but yeah.
I think Les's idea of the zero
pound kind of payment is quite
a nice way of doing it.
And that's exactly how the
subscription one works.
LES: I'm sure I said
"pound," yes.
MATT: Dollar, euro,
what have you.
KRISTAN: Yay, pesos.
LES: Pesos.
KRISTAN: All right, yeah.
I actually took a look
at the Android
documentation for this.
And it was the first time I
had looked at it today.
It seemed pretty clear how to do
an end-to-end subscription.
And I think there's some
variable time rates on
starting your billing,
et cetera.
So the best place to go,
I think, is the Android
documentation site.
And just follow that.
MATT: And they've got a really
nice Android training resource
for the in-app billing
V3 stuff, which--
if you're looking at doing this
kind of stuff or you're
already on V2, I strongly
recommend looking at V3.
It does simplify the
entire process.
And the training dock is
really, really helpful.
So yeah, definitely worth
a look at that.
KRISTAN: Let's just clarify
version numbers.
We're talking about V3,
not of Google TV.
MATT: In-app Billing Version.
In-app Billing Version 3.
KRISTAN: There you go.
CHRISTIAN: Which is available
on Google TV Version 2.
KRISTAN: Yes.
LES: And three.
KRISTAN: Which is part
of Android Version 4.
LES: No.
KRISTAN: But it's retrograde.
It goes back, I think,
to, what--
LES: It's Android Version 3.2.
KRISTAN: That's us?
LES: That's us.
KRISTAN: Lots of version
number everywhere.
All right, so, is there a way
to access content of video
container and pick and choose
tracks for playback?
This is Sebastian's question.
And he says he's looking for
Media Player track Info, which
was introduced in API 16.
So this is where it gets a
little tricky, because API 16
is not where Google TV's at.
We're on API 13.
So I actually asked some of
the engineering team today
about this, specifically
Mark Winder.
And he said I've got to talk
to the Korean team.
So I couldn't find anything
that would
necessarily allow this.
That doesn't mean it's
not possible.
But the truth of it is, you're
probably not going to have a
good time trying to use it.
So.
MATT: I think a lot of
developers are trying to do
this on the Android side,
because video playback, if you
want to do anything other than
the smallest, smallest videos
across all devices
is extremely,
extremely hard to do.
And you kind of want access to
this kind of information to
gauge whether you think your
device can handle it or not.
And there hasn't been
a way of doing it.
So yeah, unless we've added
something in, it's not looking
like it's going to--
LES: Wait.
Krispy, could you say what
Sebastian's looking for again?
KRISTAN: Yeah.
Just a sec.
Let's see.
I couldn't understand fully
the answer to my question.
Is there a problem
if we stream live
TV with adult content?
And if there is a problem,
how could it be solved?
LES: OK.
Yeah.
That's for Stoyan's.
KRISTAN: Oh, sorry.
I'm reading the wrong thing.
LES: We'll answer Stoyan's
question in a moment.
KRISTAN: All right.
Back to Sebastian's question.
Sorry.
MATT: The API with the Media
Player dock track info.
KRISTAN: Yes.
He was looking for something
like that for Google TV.
As far as I know, you can only
get limited information on the
audio stream, not the
video tracks.
Because that goes through
the trusted video path.
I don't know.
LES: Well, there might be some
information you can get that's
part of the new APIs in V3
that lets you get stuff.
And there's also, of course--
you could create a simulated
codec that gets information
for you and then all
it does is pass
onto the regular codecs.
KRISTAN: So yeah, I could
conceive of something where
somebody might take the quality
of service APIs and
also wrap that into some sort of
extreme video transcoder, I
guess, or analyzer.
If that's possible.
It seems like it might be kind
of tricky to pull off.
CHRISTIAN: I think the short
answer is we're not API 16.
This API will not work.
Doing it yourself is possible,
but it's not easy.
LES: All right.
So for Stoyan's follow-up
question, adult content can't
be in your app that we are
promoting for you.
You could do another app
that is separate.
And I do understand
that there is--
KRISTAN: Well, let's put it
in the simplest terms.
Google will not promote any
adult content applications.
LES: Right.
I will say that I did notice
that IOS, whoever they are, is
now selling adult content
in Russia, but--
excuse me.
Who knows.
But we don't, at the moment,
allow any adult content to be
promoted by us.
SHAWN: And also, most
of the OEMs.
When they feature anything, they
have pretty strict rule.
We make sure filter
all these out.
LES: This was someone else.
I was laughing because I was
talking about adult content
and someone sent a
URL to an MP4.
KRISTAN: Yeah.
It's hash coded, so who
knows what's in it.
Probably not going to click on
that while we're on air.
But John, let's see if we can
get you an answer here.
Great way to troll,
by the way.
Kidding.
So John would like to know some
info on the requirements
for streaming video content
on Android.
He's got an example.
It's an MP4.
I assume it's H.264.
He'd like to know, if possible,
if there's a working
sample project that can stream
video content currently.
So it's actually possible to
stream this MP4, assuming the
codecs match with Google TV,
with like four lines of code.
So you could have a layout
with a video view in it.
And inside your main activity,
you would capture the video
view and you would set the
content URL to the MP4.
And then you would call
video view prepare and
then video view play.
And your video will
start playing.
That's the simplest
form to go.
CHRISTIAN: I think the last
talk that we just gave at
AnDevCon, there was
actually a slide.
Yeah.
Actually, I put the
code in there.
LES: There's also on
code.google.com/
p/googletv-video-player, it
has example of all that.
Another--
in the API demos there
is stuff that
shows how to do video.
So there's plenty of content out
there for you to go take a
look at, John.
KRISTAN: Les, you want to maybe
paste the URL just to
the sample site for John
in the chat stream?
LES: Oh.
You mean doing it off the top
of one's head is not enough?
KRISTAN: I always fail at
writing things down, myself,
butter fingers and all.
But just as a follow-on to
this, John, you should be
aware that it's usually better
to stream the video than it is
to do a progressive download
and playback.
Google TVs have limited
memory.
And the hard drive space, if
you can even call it-- the
flash drive space on these
things is also rather
constrained.
So my recommendation is, if you
want to do something like
this, set up a streaming
server.
You should be able
to use something
like VLC and Handbrake.
Or there's a number of services
online that can allow
for CDN content streaming.
LES: He's got a Flash Media
server that he's
using at the moment.
So he's got all that.
Though, what you might want to
look at, John, is encoding it
multiple ways and converting it
to an NHLS, because that's
a much better way of delivering
content to your users.
KRISTAN: And it can keep your
cost down for bandwidth.
LES: Yeah.
I'm not sure-- actually--
KRISTAN: Well, it would optimize
it, potentially.
LES: Optimize it.
It provides a better
quality for--
I'm not sure you're actually
lowering your costs using it,
because it's actually using
the best quality, which--
it delivers the right quality
at the right time, which
actually might increase
your costs.
KRISTAN: Really?
Oh.
OK, I have it backwards
, then.
Yeah, it's backwards
in my head.
LES: Yeah, it's maximizing
your cost.
KRISTAN: So HLS, you can read up
on that at a large company
whose icon is a fruit.
LES: Yeah.
There is a document on--
I'll post a document,
John, to the stream.
KRISTAN: All right, I'm
going to just move us
on to the next question.
We're getting close to 2 o'clock
and I have a meeting
I've got to go to.
LES: You scheduled
it for two hours.
I was so shocked.
KRISTAN: I scheduled
what for two hours?
LES: The Hangout.
On my calendar.
KRISTAN: Did I?
LES: Yeah.
KRISTAN: Well, it looks like
we're going to be going for
another hour, folks.
No.
CHRISTIAN: I should've brought
some more food and drinks.
KRISTAN: Should've brought
some beer.
That's what we need.
Next time.
CHRISTIAN: Next year.
KRISTAN: Yes.
On the newer generation Google
TV devices, is the Drive API
integrated with Android apps?
LES: No.
KRISTAN: Unfortunately not.
If you'd like to try to figure
that out, you're welcome to.
CHRISTIAN: As far as I
know, Drive API, it's
basically just a web API.
It's like just a--
KRISTAN: It's restful.
CHRISTIAN: Just a bunch of chase
and calls and stuff.
So you can do that from
any platform.
KRISTAN: Mm-hm.
Yeah, I'd kind of be interested
to know what you
would want to use Drive
for with Google TV.
I mean, I can think of
a few scenarios.
But I'm just curious.
MATT: I think the main use
case for it is if you can
start syncing application state
across multiple devices.
Drive seems to be a nice way you
can start doing that while
also still giving the user
control of what you're syncing
if that makes sense.
You're not using a third party
circle, which they can't view
or change or delete or
have control of.
So I think that's one of the
main use cases for it that
I've seen or heard developers
kind of want.
KRISTAN: Hm.
I wonder if you could
use it as a CDN.
Although there's probably
more cost-effective
ways of doing that.
I don't know.
I'd be interested to see what
was going to come of that.
So we've covered, I believe,
all the questions
that were in the DORY.
LES: There was one more
on the + page.
KRISTAN: On the + page.
All right, let me--
MATT: Yeah, there's a good
one by Damien on there.
Or there's two on there.
KRISTAN: All right, let's see.
We have--
there is too many sources of
information for us to go on.
Let's see.
Is there a way to get notified
when a TV is
woken up from standby?
That is, boot completed doesn't
seem too useful since
people rarely complete power
down on a device.
Will a scheduled event via alarm
manager wake a device
from standing by to run?
So I actually here this one--
I don't want to say too often,
but I've heard a lot of
requests about getting notified
when a TVs woken up
or when it's shutting down or
being able to set a timer and
get it to turn on the TV.
And I think this is,
what, HDMI CDC or
something like that?
CHRISTIAN: HDMIC or something.
Yeah, there's basically
a remote control--
KRISTAN: CEC.
Thanks, Sebastian.
CHRISTIAN: --protocol that's
available over HDMI.
We don't currently have
any APIs for it.
KRISTAN: Yeah.
It's twitchy.
CHRISTIAN: It's also a little
bit vendor specific.
LES: Right.
And in fact, some of the
vendors, notably Sony, have
some CEC stuff that
they do with it.
So you might want to
check their device.
And they have a developer's
website, developers.sony.com,
that talks about their TVs.
And I bet if you wrote Toni,
T-O-N-I, there, he'd probably
be able to help you.
KRISTAN: All right, so.
David Carver asks, any plans
for a way to contribute
content to the PrimeTime app
so it can aggregate local
media for a local
media server?
An API would be ideal.
LES: It would be.
PAUL: So the answer--
not locally, there is not.
If you've got content that you
want to get discoverable,
there's kind of a
roundabout way.
But it's got to be high quality,
long-form content.
At the moment, you've got to
go as far as having TMS IDs
and all sorts of other stuff.
So if you've never broadcast
on television before, you
probably don't have that.
And it'd be a real, real
pain to get it.
So at the moment, there's really
not an easy way to get
your content into PrimeTime.
And there's nothing saying you
can't do your own self
discovery and DLMA server
stuff and that thing.
There are a couple of
apps that do that.
But that's not going to get
you into PrimeTime.
CHRISTIAN: I think a more
realistic approach would be to
have a search provider that can
provide searchable items
to the Quick Search
bar, to the QSB.
Oh yeah, that's not
a bad idea.
PAUL: The challenge with that,
though, is that when you do
that, you only get one search
result that comes in.
CHRISTIAN: And users have to
manually enable your content.
LES: Yeah.
KRISTAN: So as with everything,
this stuff will
evolve over time.
So I think it's just a
matter of stay tuned,
keep checking in.
Nothing else to announce
there, but--
LES: All right.
So I think we've covered
everybody's questions.
We haven't actually gone
through the list.
Is there anybody who's in the
Hangout who joined that has a
question that didn't
get one asked?
OK, cool.
KRISTAN: Awesome.
Thanks, guys.
Hopefully you'll tune back in
as we start off the new year
with some more Hangouts.
So just to reiterate
again, this is the
last Hangout for 2012.
You can reach us by email if you
have questions pertaining
to whatever you're doing
with Google TV.
And I hope you all have a good
holiday and New Year.
LES: I'm truly amazed.
Thank you all.
KRISTAN: Caio.
CHRISTIAN: Next year.
MATT: Have a good one.
Bye, everyone.
KRISTAN: Bye.
Ending broadcast.